[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up prof
good day walter hi martin are you doing
well
yes we're continuing our study today
ryan we have to get the armor of god on
for this one yes because then we can
partake in the battle of armageddon
correct this is
the climax of the ages
let's open with a word of prayer
thank you heavenly father for bringing
us together again
lord this is important discussions to
know what is coming and where we are
heading so please enlighten our minds
and this
discussion in jesus name amen amen
now in the first discussion that we had
we
looked at what happens when christ
returns right
and you have the resurrection of the
just
and you have the demise of the
unrighteous
and we
spoke about the events that take place
and now we have to look at it in a
little bit more detail put the lens on
it
and have a look at the battle of
armageddon because there are so many
people confused out there that think
this is a war between nations
and
what is this battle really all about so
let's dive right into it
if we go to the book of revelation
chapter 16 verse 16 and he says and he
gathered them together into a place
called in the hebrew tongue armageddon
now if we go to the book of joel
he calls it the valley of yasafat
while zachariah states that the nations
will be gathered to jerusalem
meaning that they will fight against
god's people
so it's the battle of armageddon it's
the battle at the valley of yasafat
and it is a battle that takes place at
jerusalem which one is it now
here you have the verse in joel i will
also gather all nations and will bring
them down into the valley of jehoshaphat
now these valleys had typological wars
where god fought from heaven and
destroyed
the enemy
and
used hail to destroy them
14 verse 2 i will gather all nations
against jerusalem to battle
these are all one and the same
because they are typological terms
not literal terms and it's very
important that we understand this
or else we would get
lost in the quagmire and try and make
them literal yeah
but if you give them three different
names including virtually three
different locations
then they can't be literal
then they serve a typological
purpose
so what is this battle all about
now i will gather them to this place
called armageddon
now the greek word for place is topos
and toppos has a literal meaning as well
as a metaphorical meaning and the latter
means a state of mind
so you could read it that satan will
induce a state of mind in the people of
the world that will compel them to seek
the death of those who refuse to pay
their dictates
so they will attack god's people
spiritually god's people stand for
jerusalem
typologically the enemies of god's
people were wiped out
in the valley of jehoshaphat
jerusalem is a type of god's people so
this is a battle against god's people
and the one who fights the battle we
will see
is not a nation here and there but this
is a universal issue
we must understand that israel
served as a type
for the entire world
it was the type of god's people amidst
the nations that was to take the message
to the entire world
and through
the
the ways in which god was working they
would recognize that this was the truth
but then sconced themselves and kept it
for themselves
so this served as the type of spiritual
israel
they would be scattered amongst all the
nations in the world and bring the
message to the entire world so we go
from the local to the universal
if you make it local again you're back
with the type and you miss the anti-type
revelation 16 verse 12 and the sixth
angel poured out his vial upon the great
river euphrates
and the water thereof was dried up that
the way of the kings of the east might
be prepared now so many people
take this literally as well
and have it the kings of the east either
the russians or the chinese or whatever
nation they want to put in there
and have a literal war at jerusalem and
call that the battle of armageddon
and then they will have a rapture and
then you will have the jewish nation
ruling down here on earth that's just
dispensationalism and it comes straight
out of jesuitical teaching
so we have to look at this in a little
bit now recently
the euphrates dried up
or were buzzing were busy drying up
and a lot of people sent
messages about this this exact verse
exactly
so what does this mean now we have to
look at it if we're looking at it
typologically because the whole battle
of armageddon is catched in typology
then we have to look at this euphrates
now
what
city did the euphrates serve
babylon
correct and uh
they diverted the river remember yes
when the medes and persians attacked it
and the great river dried up and the
drying up of the river was the death now
to babylon
but we've we've seen in our all of our
studies that the antitypical babylon and
we just did one on the antitypical
babylon what is babylon and what
constitutes babylon
it's not the literal babylon
so if if this is literal then it must
also be the literal euphrates and that's
what people are doing right
but if you're dealing with a great
antitype
then the river the waters are the
peoples the multitudes the nations the
kingdoms
they
fed babylon yes
in other words this anti-typical babylon
is being kept alive because it serves
the kings of the world the merchants of
the world the nations of the world
and the peoples of the world and they
all drink of the wine of a fornication
now when that river
spiritually dries up
this is the sixth plague martin
by this time people will have realized
that they've been duped
that they've been lied to and that it is
too late yes because probation is closed
already closed yes and the bible says
they will hate the
and they will turn against her
so this is the great climax that happens
here
during the sixth plague
when people realize that they've been
duped and they turn upon
babylon the system the churches this is
international this isn't a specific
place and it's among themselves and
correct this okay just to bring it into
perspective
the first plague falls at close of
probation correct
and then this is part of that great time
of trouble correct and then after the
sixth the this is the scene in the sixth
one people start realizing that they
have been duped they turn upon their
ministers who have lied to them
who have placated them and said no those
people that want to keep the law of god
and hold to
the testimony and keep the true sabbath
they are fanatics
god is with us we had the signs and the
wonders and here they're realizing
in the sixth plague
that they've been duped
and their hatred
they turn with bitterness upon them
and this prepares the way for the kings
of the east now we have to be very sure
as to who these kings of the east are
so let's go to the book of isaiah
chapter 41
let them come near
let them speak let us come near together
to judgment so what time are we talking
about
the second coming of christ because
that's when the nations will be judged
and destroyed as we saw in the previous
one
and then it says who raised up the
righteous man from the east
called him to his foot gave the nations
before him and made him rule over kings
he gave them as dust to his sword and
has driven stubble to his bone now here
you have a complete reversal
because the people out there think that
these kings from the east
or the unrighteous yes that are going to
attack but here we see that the king of
the east is the righteous one yeah who
is going to judge
so this is a reference to jesus christ
let's just make sure yeah because a lot
of people might be confused now because
now
it's coming out of the east
what's going on now
ezekiel chapter 43 verse one and two
afterwards he brought me to the gate
even the gaze that looks towards the
east
and behold the glory of the god of
israel came from the way of the east and
his voice was like the noise of many
waters and the earth shined with his
glory
what event is this also the second
coming this is the second coming of
christ so martin who is the king of the
east that comes with his army
jesus christ
in other words the battle of armageddon
is this final conflict
between the kings of the world
and the second coming of christ
now martin
do you think that the kings of the earth
through their spiritualistic contacts
remember the jesuits claim
that they are in contact with the other
side
and that they receive information
from demons
on many many issues even technology
do you think that they are being
prepared for a cosmic war
yes because
most countries like we've shown already
have implemented space force
military
correct they've held all kinds of
interesting exercises
and
we don't want to go into too many
details but you know some of them were
had interesting names operation fishbowl
where they shot missiles up into the sky
and had nuclear exercises
are the kings of the world
preparing everyone for an invasion
yes an alien invasion yes are the movies
doing it doing it
you've got all this
in the media now about the pentagon
releasing all this info and this
investigation that they have on ufos
it's
rampant do you think it's remotely
possible that mankind can be so deceived
that they think they might be able to
divert the second coming of christ or
even blow it out of the sky well
with everything happening in the world
it's not
surprising me anymore nothing surprises
us anymore okay
so the one who comes from the east is
jesus christ and his angels
revelation 19
from verse 13 tells us and he was
clothed with the vesture dipped in blood
and his name is called the word of god
now we know who that is yeah john tells
us quite plainly that that is jesus
christ right
and the armies
which were in heaven followed him upon
white horses
clothed in fine linen white and clean so
is this a military action yes it's a
military action
so jesus is coming
and he has his armies with him and those
armies are not human no
they are angelic
and out of his mouth goes a sharp sword
that with it he should smite the nations
did we see that in the previous one that
we discussed correct
and he shall rule them with a rod of
iron and he treadeth the winepress of
the fierceness and wrath of almighty god
so who is the one who is fighting this
war jesus and his angels what happened
at the bottle battle of jehoshaphat
the angels fought from heaven and
destroyed the enemies of israel with
hail
that's the seventh plague martin yeah
so this will be a similar war that was
like you said it's a type this is
anti-type
that was local
this is universal
revelation 16 verse 18 and there were
voices and thunders and lightnings and
there was a great earthquake
such as was not since men were upon the
earth so mighty and earthquake and so
great
this takes place in the seventh plague
and the cities of the nations fell
now in the previous lecture we saw that
the earth was destroyed
there were no animals
no birds
no man and all the cities were flattened
so was this an earthly batten or was it
christ that destroyed them
it was christ
and every island fled away and the
mountains were not found so every valley
will be raised every mountain will come
crashing down can you imagine that
earthquake
unbelievable
and there fell upon men a great hail out
of heaven every stone about the weight
of a talon
a martin this is amazing this is a
description of the seventh plague
and men blasphemed god
because of the plague of the hail for
the plague thereof was exceeding great
so who does this fall on if they
blaspheme
on the unrighteous
samadhin this is the battle of our
magetton
and it is being fought
at a place
topos
it's being fought against the mindset
now if you look at the world today
are there
different
mindsets that are developing
yes
do some people feel that the mindset of
the ruling powers is becoming more and
more tyrannical
coercive
using force
and when they start using force to
enforce even
religious dogmas
then you must know that the writing is
on the wall right
so this is the final battle that takes
place
all right so what does job say he says
hast thou entered into the treasures of
the snow
or hast thou seen the treasures of the
hail
which i have reserved against the time
of trouble against the day of battle and
war
so even in the old testament
and this book of job was written by
moses yes
moses already saw the final battle
and he knew that god has hail stored up
for the time of trouble
we know when that is yeah
and against the day of battle and war so
these are the weapons
they are
heavenly weapons
and god will
destroy humanity
the wicked humanity
at that battle
so the living wicked die
and the dead wicked remain dead a
thousand years how important is it
that we develop a mindset that is in
harmony with the bible absolute because
if your mindset is not
like this you will be waiting for an
earthly kingdom and
this earthly war
and then you will be trusting in earthly
kings exactly and you'll be waiting for
an earthly savior whether you call him q
anon or whatever
you're just waiting for that savior to
come
no
the hope is in another savior
and a lot of your interpretation will be
on earthly events correct
our hope is in nothing less
than jesus and his righteousness
so this long awaited the millennium a
number of years ago time had this uh
front cover at the end of the world and
they talk about the millennium madness
and people are looking forward to this
and they're looking to the rapture
and there's nothing like it in the
scriptures
yeah there was
i mean it was
when it went over from 99 from 1999 till
2000 that was a huge one and then you
had the 2012 end of the world
corrections that was when that planet
was the asteroid was supposed to strike
the earth right
now in the year 2000 i actually was on
an airplane
flying to do a campaign
it was the best flight i've ever had the
plane was virtually empty and i could
lie down at my leisure and
have a good snooze
instead of sitting cramped in your
little seat because everybody was too
scared to fly
but yeah that's what happens when people
attack
prophecies out of context
so martin between the first resurrection
as we have seen and the second
resurrection there's a period of a
thousand years
but that thousand years unfortunately
for those who believe that
does not take place on earth
because the righteous have been taken
away yeah and there's nothing left on
earth
so we have to ask the question what
about the righteous during the
millennium what do they do
revelation 20 verse 6 tells us what they
do they shall be priests of god and of
christ and they shall reign with him a
thousand years
imagine when you reign with someone
has that got to do with government yes
all right
no matter
the righteous
do they now become the government of
heaven and rule over the angels
no
obviously not so
what kind of rain is this right
how do they reign together
with christ
and
what do they do in terms of reigning now
when you reign
over someone
then
you also apply the law
correct because that's what governments
do they're there to maintain
law
and order
so in what way do they reign
verse 4 i saw thrones and they sat upon
them and judgment was given unto them
this is a very important verse
and it corroborates daniel 7 22 and
judgment was given to the saints yes now
this happens during the millennium
now obviously everybody has already been
judged
because the righteous were resurrected
so they must have been judged
the living righteous were translated
and the
unrighteous were condemned
and the unrighteous dead weren't
resurrected yes so so the judgment has
already taken place
this
verdict has been given the verdict has
been given and who who gave that verdict
jesus christ doesn't the bible say all
judgment has been given unto him yes so
he has judged everyone
martin you want to be in that judgment
but you want to be in the judgment that
took place before christ came
in that investigative judgment
because
if he didn't give judgment
in your favor
during the investigative phase you
wouldn't be part of this judgment that
he's handed over to you
all right so in what way does this take
place well obviously
people will want to know
how god judged
why god judged the way that he did so in
other words i call this a judgment of
verification
god's people will get the chance to see
why aunt mary and aunt sophie
and uncle tom
that seemed so nice
out there
and why manasseh
who murdered so many people
and nebuchadnezzar the proud king of
babylon
why is he there
right
and why are there some individuals
missing in some present
and what happened here on earth what
happened behind closed doors
what happened in those secret meetings
where certain things were planned
whatever was done in secret will be what
revealed and will be shouted from the
rooftop
so now judgment was given to them so the
books were there
so now you can study
and find out exactly
whether god's judgment was
absolutely fair
and this is the sense
god's people will be given an
opportunity
to have insight into the judgment of
jesus christ
to make absolutely sure
that everything was fair
so that every question every doubt
will be answered
so 1 corinthians 6 verse 2 and 3 says do
you not know that saints shall judge the
world
know ye not that we shall judge angels
now martin what angels will we judge the
fallen ones obviously right the other
ones need no judgment
so these are the fallen angels
so
were these fallen angels already judged
weren't they thrown out of heaven yes
now who did that judgment jesus
exactly so now here this is what they
will do
we will look at the whole
plan of salvation
and the whole controversy issue the
battle between good and evil from its
inception in heaven
all the way through to the end how many
billions of individuals are there to be
judged yeah
almost
like the sand of the sea
that will take a while yeah
it'll take a while and every nuance of
history
wouldn't it be interesting
to see what happened behind the scenes
in certain corridors in certain chambers
wouldn't it be interesting to know what
was the real history
and those final questions what happened
to kennedy
what happened to abraham lincoln
what happened in the various nations of
europe what happened
between the religious systems and the
secular systems what happened in africa
what happened in southern africa
fascinating questions
we're going to be very busy martin
and we will have to judge according to
the law
that's it so that's ruled that's what
christ that's what jesus used
so the judgment
then shows that god did everything that
he could to save every person
there will still be some question marks
the question mark will be
what if i could have reached that person
surely if they see clearly
they can change their minds right
this requires a second resurrection
yes and then of course justice demands
that the unrighteous
face the consequences that they should
be informed as to why
and where they made their choice
right yeah this requires a
resurrection this requires the
tyrants of the world to be resurrected
to stand before a tribunal that cannot
be duped
right yeah and even those angels
that will stand with them there correct
and then the righteous will say once
they've been through that book
and those books and it'll take a
thousand years
they will say even so lord god almighty
true and righteous are
thy judgments you were fair
it's correct we can find
no
fault the fault does not lie with the
god of heaven the fault lies with
the rebellious ones from the angels all
the way
through
humanity there's another thing that
happens during the thousand years martin
we have a lot of catching up to do
we have a lot of catching up to do in
terms of knowledge
because surely we have been fed lives oh
yes i'd love to know what the truth is
behind some of these things that we are
being fed on a daily basis by the media
and not only that we have to grow
into the full stature of heavenly beings
that takes another thousand years
physically mentally
spiritually
that is amazing
so during the millennium the righteous
are in heaven the earth is desolate
satan is bound the judgment of
verification takes place in heaven is
that biblical yes we've seen it
then we have to come to
the culmination of all things and when
the thousand years are expired
satan shall be loosed out of his prison
and shall go out to deceive the nations
so what loosens him out of his prison
the resurrection of the unrighteous
because then he can deceive them again
correct so deception is the name of his
game
he has to destroy the city and christ
if he wants to survive because the
alternative is christ is going to
destroy him
and he's not giving up so now
christ raises the multitudes
the billions
from the pre-flood world all the way
through to the battle of armageddon he
raises them all and they're like the
sand of the sea
and satan sees his army
and he
goes amongst them and says let's take
the city
a final battle
now why does god permit that
so that those who had still a little bit
of doubt
could see
the result okay so that meek and mild
little one that you thought
should
be there or could possibly be there when
you see the animosity in that face on
the outside of the city
you realize that god's judgment of
character was perfect yes so maybe we
can say
maybe there wasn't even any doubt but
that's just another stamp on exactly
that
his judgment was fair correct
so in other words what enables this is
the resurrection of damnation which
takes place now only christ can
resurrect because he's the author of
life
zachariah explains then shall the lord
go forth and fight against those nations
as when he fought in the day of battle
let's just stop there
there are two battles that are being
highlighted here
there's going to be this final battle
the lord shall go forth and fight
against all those resurrected nations
after the millennium how
as when he fought in the previous battle
that was armageddon the second coming so
there are two battles
the battle of armageddon at the coming
of christ
and now this battle which will be
similar to the one when he destroyed
them during armageddon
and then it says and his feet shall
stand in that day upon the mount of
olives
which is before jerusalem on the east
and the mount of olives shall cleave in
the midst thereof towards the east and
towards the west
and there shall be a very great valley
and half of the mountain shall remove
towards the north and half of it towards
the south
so what is different here is that his
feet touch the ground
what happened at
the battle of armageddon did not touch
the ground we had to meet him in the air
right
okay so this is not the same occasion
and it's so important that we separate
them
because god gives very precise clues
so this one is after millennium because
it is the second war he's going to fight
as he did previously
this is the second war
revelation 21 verse 2 and i john saw the
holy city the new jerusalem coming down
from god out of heaven prepared as a
bride adorned for a husband
so that whole city the new jerusalem
that god had prepared for those that
love him
comes down like a mighty mother
spaceship
and lands on that prepared portion
where his feet are touched so when he
touches this cursed earth
a plane
that is purified by his touch
is created and onto that plane
the great city descends
and this is when the resurrection of the
unjust takes place
and then they encompass the city to war
against it and this is when that next
battle takes place
so let's read it revelation 20 verse 7.
now it's very important
we're now in the second arm of the book
of revelation
and the book of revelation has a
chiastic structure
and the highlight is in the middle
revelation 12 11 13 to 17
that is the end time
issues
the second half after that is in the
second arm of the chiasm
so the events described in it are given
in reverse order
because the chiasm works like that
this one is working towards the middle
from the back to the middle
and the first one is working from the
front to the middle so this is the
historic arm
of the book of revelation
and this is the eschatological arm so
you can get very confused yes if you
don't take the chiasm into consideration
you will read the events in reverse and
become confused yes your sequence will
be out your sequence will be out you
must take the sequence this way because
it's pointing to the end times events
particularly the mark of the beast
implication the fall of babylon etc
so let's read this now we're in the
eschatological arm
when the thousand years are expired
satan shall be loosed out of his prison
and shall go out to deceive the nations
which are on the four quarters of the
earth this is after the millennium
gogen magog
to gather them together to battle
the number of whom is as the sand of the
sea so these are the resurrected
billions
great statured men from the antediluvian
world
kane
and llame and nimrod after the flood all
of these giant people
and there's a battle that takes place
and the battle is called gogen magog
so you had a battle armageddon took
place before the millennium
now you're going to have a war
called gorgon magog
the first one was topos a mindset
we'll see what this one is
so they are gathered together for this
battle this is a wall
and they went up on the breadth of the
earth encompassed the camp of the saints
about and the beloved city this is the
new jerusalem
not to be confused with the earthly
jerusalem cannot because that's been
destroyed yeah
okay
and how does god fight fire came down
from god out of heaven and devoured them
and the devil that deceived them was
cast into the lake of fire and brimstone
where the beast and the false prophet
are and shall be tormented day and night
forever and ever
now some people say all right now this
means that there will be an eternal hell
but we'll see what it really means in a
moment
the fact of the matter is
the beast and the false prophet they'd
been thrown into that
death pit
before when was that at the second
coming at the battle of armageddon yes
so they'd been already destroyed the
only portion that was left was the
dragon
the devil
now it's his turn to be thrown there
okay
and i saw the dead small and great stand
before god and the books were opened and
another book was opened which is the
book of life
and the dead were judged out of those
things which were written in the books
according to their works
and the sea gave up the dead which were
therein and death and hell hardest
the grave
delivered up the dead which were in them
and they were judged every man according
to their works
and death and hell were cast into the
lake of fire
now we get a definition this is very
important
this is the second death so they died
the first death
from which there was a resurrection yes
now they die a second death
and whosoever was not found written in
the book of life was cast into the like
of fire which is the second earth that's
it
so they die a second death so this lake
of fire this second death lasts how long
forever
exactly
this second death
this lake of fire
lasts forever and ever there's no
resurrection from this they are gone
forever the bible tells us explicitly
that they are gone
all right now people get confused
because there was a war and fire came
down from heaven
and now there's a resurrection
and there's a judgment so they think
it's part of the first coming okay you
see that you can get confused yes if you
don't read it right if you don't take
the chiasm into account so if we take
the chiasm into account what we have
is a resurrection
a judgment according to the books
everyone knows exactly
why they are not in the city
they
explicitly explained
they see the course of their actions
and satan tries to convince them
let's take the city yes
but fire comes down from heaven
and consumes them
in job we read in chapter 21 verse 30
that the wicked are reserved to the day
of destruction
they shall be brought forth to the day
of wrath
so there's a resurrection they are
brought forth out of the graves
for what
destruction not an eternal hell so
that's symbolic language
and the fire that destroys them
is a fire with eternal
consequences yes
and this is called
the battle of gog and magog
so the bible said as we read he comes
down his feet touch the mount of olives
it splits it creates the great plain
he resurrects the unrighteous
they appear before the tribunal
they first have a period of time to
prepare
and then they come before the judgment
seat the great white throne rises above
the city
they are judged satan tries to take the
city
the battle of gog and magog takes place
now what does that mean
it means concealed
that's very interesting
because everything he did was in secret
yes
this is the way he works
so
babylon was called
mystery
so here you have this concealed hidden
diabolical
abusous religion
and it is revealed when the books are
opened
all the unrighteousness is revealed and
the righteous had judged
and all of them know exactly
why
they are not
part
of the city
revelation 20 verse 9.
so let's look at this war
and they went up on the breadth of the
earth encompassed the camp of the saints
about and the beloved city so here they
are all around the city the new
jerusalem the new jerusalem
revelation 20 verse 9 after this
judgment
fire came down from god out of heaven
and devoured them what does devoured
mean destroyed nothing left they're
destroyed god is not vindictive no he's
not going to
burn you for all eternity
and
unfortunately like we've said uh in the
pre previously
it's not actually god destroying them
it's their choices that was clinging to
sin and didn't want to confess it
that's causing this that's why the bible
says our god is a consuming
fire
but like those three hebrew worthies
if you are in christ the fire does not
consume you you're in the fire but
you're not consumed there's not even a
smell
of fire on you
so let's have a little closer look at
this doctrine of hell
these are the works of samuel hopkins
this is a catholic view of hell
the smoke of their torment shall ascend
up forever in the sight of the blessed
now they're quoting those verses
before their eyes this display of divine
character and glory will be in favor of
the redeemed
and most entertaining
and give the highest pleasure to those
who love god
should the eternal torment and fires be
extinguished it would in a great measure
put an end to the happiness and glory of
the blessed now martin you must have a
very warped mind to write something like
that
you see that's just where i think
humanity is at this stage
they actually
feel good if they see somebody getting
is just you
absolutely
now this is a very warped thing because
imagine
you are a parent
and one of your children is not there or
you are a child
and one of your parents is not there or
both of them
and for all eternity you have to see
them roast in hell
would that add to your pleasure
it would make heaven
a place of eternal misery
so it is not in harmony with the
character of god because we read in
ezekiel 33 11 as i live says the lord
god i have no pleasure in the death of
the wicked
but that the wicked turn from his way
and live turn ye turn you from your evil
ways for why will you die o house of
israel
we have a god of compassion we don't
have a vindictive god
ezekiel 18 verse 32 i have no pleasure
in the death of him that dieth
so how can his followers have pleasure
in those that suffer eternal tillman
isaiah 55 7 says let the wicked forsake
his way and the unrighteous man his
thoughts
and let him return unto the lord and he
will have mercy upon him and to our god
for he will abundantly pardon this is
the kind of god we serve
now the catechism of the catholic church
states in article 103 5
the teachings of the church affirms the
existence of hell
and its eternity
immediately after death the souls of
those who die in a state of mortal some
descent into hell
where they suffer the punishment of hell
eternal fire
the chief punishment of hell is eternal
separation from god in whom alone man
can possess the life and happiness for
which he was created
and for which he longs so the modern
catechism
confirms
the doctrine of the roman catholic
church it is a horrendous doctrine
that places god's character in such a
terrible light
that in the middle ages
they're ruled by fear
of this deity
if we take a modern pope like pope john
paul ii in 1994 in his book crossing the
threshold of hope he wrote
that too often preachers catechists and
teachers no longer have the courage to
preach the threat of hell
concerning the reality of hell the pope
says
in point of fact the ancients council
rejected the theory according to which
the world would be regenerated after
destruction
and every creature would be saved a
theory which abolished hell
the words of christ are unequivocal
matthew gospel he speaks clearly of
those who will go to eternal punishment
but who will these be the church has
never made any pronouncement in this
regard
so the fact of the matter is he says
there's the literal hell
and he again applies god's words jesus
words in matthew
talking about an eternal punishment
the consequences are eternal as we have
seen
this is also
interesting in terms of how they think
these are the exercises of lyola this is
the jesuit order
and they have a meditation
which they do on hell
the jesuits
it says the first prelude is the
composition which is here to see with
the sight of the imagination the length
and breadth and depth of hell
it's amazing right so you go into a
imaginative trance state
and then you have to imagine hell and
then you ask
for what i want
it will be here to ask for interior
sense of the pain which the damned
suffer
in order that if through my faults i
should forget the love of the eternal
lord at least the fear of the pains may
help me not to come into sin
is that a good motive martin no so again
it's driven by fear it's a terrible
motive
then it get to the first point which
will be to see with the sight because
remember in
their thinking you have to use all your
senses yeah
so you have to see with your sight of
the imagination the great fires and the
souls as the bodies of fire
and then the second point is to hear
with the ears wailing and howlings and
cries and blasphemies against christ our
lord and against all his saints why
would you want to hear that martin
you might as well switch on jesuit
theater and look at the movie and you'll
hear this enough the blasphemy is
against
christ and then the third is to smell
with the smell smoke sulfur drinks and
putrid things
and the fourth is to taste with taste
the bitter things like tears sadness and
the worm of conscience
and the fifth is touch that is to say
how the fires touch and burn the soul
this is a
terrible terrible exercise but this just
fits in with the modern paradigm
of fear
god explicitly says in his word do not
fear yes perfect love drives out fear
that's it and what is the means of
satan coercion and fear and fear and
even if you go to stress and all of
these certain diseases that you get it's
driven by fear if you've got stress
you're fearing something correct
absolutely and
one of the leaders in in germany has now
just said
that
the method of dealing with the
with
pestilences
is vaccination and vaccination then
becomes the moses that will save us out
of our demise this is horrendous way of
thinking
here's another catholic way of thinking
about this catholic answers the hell
there is the doctrine of hell is so
frightening that numerous heretical
sects
end up denying the reality of an eternal
hell i wonder what they're talking about
you and me martin sure they whether
they're talking about tyndall whether
they're talking about luther because
they all fall into that category yeah
well then once again like paul said if
that is what they no
actually they actually mentioned they
actually mentioned me are the unitarian
universalists the seventh-day adventists
the jehovah's witnesses the
christiadelphians
the christian scientists and the
religious scientists and the new ages
and the mormons they have a good list as
to who believes what right
all have rejected or modified the
doctrine of health so radically that it
is no longer a serious threat
in recent decades this decay has even
invaded mainstream evangelicalism
and a number of major evangelical
figures have advocated the view that
there is no eternal hell the wicked will
simply be annihilated well that's what
the bible says well it's interesting to
me they include new ages here or even if
you want to put it occultists like you
said earlier you were dabbling in this
even though you were an atheist correct
yeah so
it's it's interesting how
it works
this covers
the whole spectrum of people that
don't want to believe that um it's
asleep correct now
it's interesting that catholicism pushes
this with such a
vigorous agenda right
here's another one from the catholic
sauce cyril of jerusalem he wrote
we shall be raised therefore all with
our bodies eternal but not all with
bodies alike
for if a man is righteous he will
receive a heavenly body that he may be
able worthily to hold converse with the
angels
but if a man is a sinner he shall
receive an eternal body now where did we
read that the wicked receive an eternal
body they were consumed right
fitted to endure the penalties of sin
that he may burn eternally in fire nor
ever be consumed
so god is
such a tyrant that he'll give you a
super body to be able to take the pain
and it's actually
going right
against what the bible says because the
bible says you'll be consumed
what does this make of god a tyrant
and righteously will god assign this
portion to either company for we doing
nothing without the body we blaspheme
with the mouth and with the mouth we
pray with the body we commit fornication
with the body we keep chastity with the
hand we rob and by the hand we bestow
arms and the rest in like manner since
then the body has been our minister in
all things
it shall also share with us in the
future of the fruits of the past so you
have to get a body in order to suffer
eternally
totally unscriptural
they take a
symbol
and they turn it into an eternal
reality
matthew 10 28 and fear not them which
kill the body
but are not able to kill the soul
but rather fear them which is able to
destroy both soul and body in hell
in other words the whole human being
everything pertaining to him and hell
there is hardest the fire
the hyena the fire that destroys
and death and hell were cast into the
lake of fire this hyena
that is the second death there's a
definition there's a definition and if
you apply the definition
then
there's no more need for a discourse on
it
and revelation 20 verse 15 and whosoever
was not found written in the book of
life was cast into the lake of fire in
other words died the second earth
and turning to the cities of sodom and
gomorrah ii
peter and they turning them into ashes
condemned them with an overthrow making
them an example unto those that should
live ungodly and jude corroborates it
and he says that in like manner giving
over to fornication and going after
strange flesh are set forth as an
example suffering the vengeance of
eternal fire
so
they are an example is sodom and
gomorrah still here no are the people of
sodom and gomorrah still here no they've
been destroyed right
they will have a resurrection
but they will become ashes again
now that was the catholic view that we
heard let's have a look at death and
hell in the quran
this gets very interesting
surah 2 verse 81 indeed those who earn
sins and become surrounded by their evil
work will be dwellers of hell
they abide in it forever so the same
doctrine yes
as for those who believe and lead a
righteous life they will be dwellers of
paradise they abide in it forever
is that a catholic view they go to
heaven
surah 4 56 indeed those who disbelieve
in our verses we will drive them into a
fire
now what happens there every time their
skins are roasted through we will
replace them with other skins so they
may taste the punishment indeed allah is
forever exalted and mighty and wise
so martin you go there you burn your
skin off and you get a new skin every
day so you can see you feel the same
pain again
uh what kind of god is that
definitely not a loving god definitely
not the god of the bible
surah 18 29
say the truth is from your lord let him
who will believe and let him who will
reject it for the wrongdoers we have
prepared a fire
whose smoke and flames like the walls
and roof of a tent will hem them in
if they implore relief they will be
granted water like melted brass
that will scald their faces how dreadful
the drink how uncomfortable a couch to
recline on
this sounds like
those catholic ones that we read that
you get a special body to take the pain
right
surah 14 49
and they will see the sinners that day
bound together in fetters their garments
liquid pitch and their faces covered
with fire
so this seems to me to be a view
[Music]
that is specifically
contradictory to the word of god
so let's ask the question how long will
the ungodly burn
right yeah because it becomes important
question exactly because
they say it will be forever correct
well psalms 37 20 but the wicked shall
perish and the enemies of the lord shall
be as the fat of lambs they shall
consume
into smoke they shall consume away
what does that say
well there's nothing going to be left
that's pretty plain though yeah
it's not allegorical
what about twenty verse nine and five
fire came down from out from god out of
heaven and devoured them
nothing left
what about obadiah 16 they shall be as
though they had not been how plain is
that martin
i don't think you can put it in plainer
can you argue against that
you see
if you take a complicated verse that
uses complicated images
and you
make them literal then you end up with
these terrible doctrines
whereas if you take the plain
straightforward statement like we are
reading here
and that is your basis
then you know that your interpretation
of those complicated verses must be in
harmony with the plain statements of the
bible otherwise the bible is
contradicting itself right exactly and
this is how you do study malachi 4 verse
tells you what happens after they're
destroyed
and you shall trample the wicked for
they shall be ashes under the souls of
your feet in the day which i am
preparing says the lord of hosts is that
plain that is crystal clear so once that
process is over
the righteous come out of the city and
they walk on ashes
there's no everlasting hell
psalms 37 verse 20 into smoke they shall
consume away
psalms 21 9 the foul shall devour them
revelation 20 verse 14 this is the
second death it is an eternal death
the punishment is eternal
not the fire yeah
so when the bible says in matthew 25 46
and these shall go into everlasting
punishment but the righteous into life
eternal
then you have to read it in the context
of those verses
right
so what is everlasting the punishment or
the consequences the consequences the
consequences are everlasting
same with revelation 14 11 and the smoke
of their torment has sent us up forever
and ever they have no rest day or night
who worship the beast and his image and
whosoever receives the mark of his name
now this is the verse that is used to
corroborate hell
it has to be in harmony with the plain
ones right
now
we've already seen that the punishment
is eternal
now they have no rest day or night
what kind of rest are we talking here
now we're talking about the rest of
those that are alive
but do not find rest
or did they not find the rest of god
they did not rest
in the completed work of god
they did not rest in the righteousness
of god
and forever and ever
they are ashes
because they have rejected the plan of
salvation that's what the verse means
and nothing more because if it meant
something else
you would have to negate all the other
verses in the bible
psalms 92 verse 7 makes it very plain
when the wicked spring up as the grass
and when all the workers of iniquity do
flourish it is that they shall be
destroyed
forever
so it's not the punishment that is
forever it is the destruction
that is for all eternity
wickedness will not raise its head a
second time
it's a complete end
to the rebellion that started in heaven
so let's read another complicated verse
for it is the day of the lord's
vengeance and the year of recompenses
for the controversy of zion
and the streams thereof shall be turned
into pitch and the dust thereof into
brimstone and the land thereof shall be
burning pitch that's the destruction
right martin
it shall not be quenched night nor day
the smoke thereof shall go up forever
from generation to generation it shall
lie waste none shall pass through it
forever and ever
again you have a verse which
seems to imply
that the fire never goes out
right it seems like this so we have to
look at those verses
we have to find parallels in the bible
jude 1 verse 7 remember the destruction
of sodom and gomorrah and the cities
around which served as an example of
those suffering the vengeance of eternal
fire
is the fire still burning no
so the consequences are still there aha
so when it talks about this fire
that is forever
then
you have an example sodom and gomorrah
they're suffering the vengeance of
eternal fire
the fire's not burning anymore
it must refer to the consequences
let's go
to second peter again it's exactly the
same thing making them an example of
those that should live ungodly
they will be destroyed exactly
but let's make absolutely sure in the
book of jeremiah you have a beautiful
example
where the bible speaks about fire that
will not be quenched
and it's talking about the destruction
of jerusalem
but if you will not hearken unto me to
hallow the sabbath martin is very
interesting that jeremiah here in the
type
in in jeremiah 17 27
is foretelling the destruction of
jerusalem
and the sabbath was a very important
issue yes that was the type
so you'll have exactly the same issue at
the end the mark of the beast
but if you will not hearken unto me to
hallow the sabbath day and not to bear a
burden even entering in at the gates of
jerusalem on the sabbath day
then will i kindle a fire in the gates
thereof and it shall devour the palaces
of jerusalem and it shall not be
quenched
it's an unquenchable fire yes
the consequence cannot be changed
correct let's just make sure
verse 12 and 13 in chapter 52 is the
fulfillment
now in the fifth month in the tenth day
of the month which was the 19th year of
nebuchadnezzar king of babylon
came nebu zaradan captain of the god
which served the king of babylon into
jerusalem and burnt the house of the
lord
and the king's house and all the houses
of jerusalem and all the houses of the
great men burnt here with fire this
serves as a type
of this final destruction okay
ii chronicles picks up the story
in chapter 36 from verse 19.
and they burnt the house of god they
break down the wall of jerusalem and
they burnt all the palaces thereof with
fire and destroyed all the goodly
vessels thereof
and them that had escaped from the sword
carried the away to babylon
where they were servants to him and his
sons until the reign of the kingdom of
persia to fulfill the words of the lord
by the mouth of jeremiah
until the land had enjoyed her sabbaths
for as long as she laid desolate she
kept sabbath to fulfill three score and
ten years
this is a very interesting verse to
fulfill
the word of the lord by the mouth of
jeremiah he said the fire would not be
quenched
is it still burning no
not literally
exactly so this is
metaphorical language
and it's interesting
that there was a sabbath rest for the
land
now the millennium is a thousand years
is that
is that a millennium of rest not yes
it's letting the earth rest forth
yes
so if we go back martin to malachi 4
verse 1 and behold the day cometh that
shall burn as an oven
and all the proud yea and all that do
wickedly shall be stubble
and the day that comes shall burn them
up says the lord of hosts
that it shall leave them neither root
nor branch so this fire will not be
quenched
until it has done its job
till everything is stubble everything
has been burnt up that's what it means
exactly if you make a fire
and there's nothing that quenches it and
tomorrow you come there what's left ash
nothing dash ash
and fear not them which kill the body
but which are not able to kill the soul
which is the combination of
the dust of the earth and the breath
but rather fear him which is able to
destroy both soul and body in hell the
greek there is hyena this fire this
unquenchable fire
and if you do not do
due diligence with your bible study
you will end up where the quran ends up
and where roman catholicism ends up
so if you go to this word hyena
then we look at the origin hell is the
place of the future punishment called
hyena or hyena of fire
this was originally the valley of hinum
south of jerusalem where the filth and
dead animals of the city were cast out
and burned
a fit symbol of the wicked and their
future
destruction
so the greek hardest and the hebrew
shall refer to the place of the dead
the grave
and it's interesting that in many many
places
when they
translate it they translated hell
but it actually means hardest or they
translate hyena as hell as well so it
becomes very confusing
so the question then arises what happens
to satan
ezekiel 28 verse 16 and onwards make it
clear
i will destroy thee o covering cherub
therefore will i bring forth a fire in
the midst of thee and it shall devour
thee and i will bring thee to ashes upon
the earth
it's interesting that the fire comes out
of the midst of him because that's where
sin originated exactly in him
and it burns him up
and he becomes ashes he will be no more
revelation 21 verse 3 and 22 verse 4 and
i heard a great voice out of heaven
saying behold the tabernacle of god is
with men
and he will dwell with them and they
will be his people and god himself shall
be with them and be their god
and they shall see his face
imagine if you can see his face
then you must be able to stand
in the fire of his presence
right
and not be consumed but if you have sin
on you you will be consumed
and then the good news
revelation 21 verse 1 and i saw a new
heaven and a new earth for the first
heaven and the first earth
were passed away what does that mean
it's gone there's no reminder
it's gone
and what will it be like isaiah 11 69
and the wolf also shall dwell with the
lamb
and the leopard shall lie down with the
kid and the calf and the young lion and
the fatling together and a little child
shall lead them in other words god is
going to recreate
i'm wondering if it's going to take
about six days
well i don't think god will
it says god never changes well
it's pure speculation
but imagine standing there
and
watching the process now the bible says
that the sons of god that's the angelic
host and the unfallen beings rejoiced
and sang together when this earth was
created
but we weren't there
so now we will see it being recreated
so let's be faithful to the end
it also says that we are sons and
daughters of god correct the righteous
yes
now this little child that will lead the
lion
and
there will be no aggression in that
animal anymore
and the cow and the bear shall feed
their young ones shall lie down together
and the lion shall be a vegetarian
martin
it shall eat straw like the ox
and the sucking child shall play on the
whole of the asp and the weaned child
shall put his hand on the cochran's dem
they shall not hurt nor destroy in all
my holy mountain for the earth shall be
full of the knowledge of the lord as the
waters cover the sea so the curse will
be gone
it'll go back to the original creation
there'll be no more death
so the lion cannot be a carnivore
because what if he eats your favorite
pet right yeah it's not going to happen
that's going back to the original
this fire would have cleansed the whole
earth and now this all the animals are
being recreated
and then this beautiful
picture of the new world isaiah 65 23
they shall not labor in vain nor bring
forth for trouble
for they are the seed of the blessed of
the lord and their offspring with them
so this is a description of the new
world that god will create
and
god's families will still be together
and you've created a new heaven and a
new earth and the former thing shall not
be remembered nor come to mind
imagine if there's an eternal
burning hell
will you not remember will it not come
to mind all the time yesterday there
will be a constant reminder
so the story of redemption is a
beautiful story
and what will we do in this new world
they shall build houses
and inhabit them and they shall plant
vineyards and eat the fruit of them they
shall not build and another inhabit
they shall not plant in another eat for
as the days of a tree are the days of my
people and mine elect shall long enjoy
the work of their hands how long
forever if you're immortal then that
means forever
so martin let's make it quite plain
you will possess
two houses
one prepared to you
for you by god yes in the city a city
dwelling
so that when you come
to worship god in the city if you come
to the celestial city
then you have your own place you won't
have to get a hotel
you won't have to go and find a stable
because the place is booked up
you will have your own place
prepared for you
by god
then he creates a new world
and you get a piece of land
where you build your own house
and you plant vineyards
and you eat the fruit of them and nobody
is going to disinherit you
or pull a political trick on you and
disenfranchise you
and it shall come to pass that from one
new moon to another and from one sabbath
to another shall all flesh come to
worship before me says the lord
so here's a monthly feast
[Music]
and a weekly feast
now what do you do in the monthly feast
to eat of the fruits of the tree of life
the bible says that the tree bears its
fruit once a month so once a month you
partake of the tree of life and it bears
12 different kinds of fruits right
so there's variety there
and the sabbath will be an eternal
institution
so
does humanity have to keep the sabbath
yes yes you'll be keeping it for all
eternity
and this is
the totality of the plan of salvation
and it shows the character of god
god is just
and god is the god of his word
the wages of sin is death death
eternal death all right god gave
opportunity for repentance
and he created a situation
where
that death
took hold of you but if you had laid
hold of the promise of redemption in
christ
then that second death has no power over
you and if i can then just summarize
from what i have understood out of this
we are living in the time just before
the close of probation right now correct
the then will follow the plague and the
close of probation will
happen when the mark of the beast is
being enforced correct then people have
a short window of opportunity yeah to
decide either
for the government of god and his
authority or the government of man and
their authority
then comes the destruction in the
plagues the plagues that we've seen and
in the seventh plague you have the
battle of armageddon that's it
and then
then you have the millennium
where the righteous
judge the world
and verify that god's
judgments are just yes
then you have the
return of the city to this earth a plane
is created
the dead
that are lying there for
the last millennium
since the beginning of this great
controversy are raised
they receive their judgment
they make a final effort to attack the
city
they are destroyed by fire that cannot
be quenched until everything has been
consumed and that battle is called gog
and gog and magog a second battle
and it is to make plain everything that
has been concealed
whereas the first one
dealt with the mindset that has been
induced because of the deception
so the topos the armageddon it's a
battle against the mindset
the second one is to make plain
everything that had been concealed so
that nobody has any more doubt on the
issue
then after that destruction god
recreates the world in its perfect
beauty
and the inhabitants of the city
go out they receive a portion of land
they build their houses and they live
lives
as ambassadors for god's cause
throughout the universe
and the guarantee
that sin will never raise its head again
because we've experienced it in our
flesh
and if somebody in the future
billions of years from now should say i
wonder whether god is fair when i don't
think it'd get past that
because the redeemed will come down on
him like a ton of bricks and sort his
head out right
but the bible promises
it will not raise its head a second time
because the marks in his hand
and the witness of the redeemed
will be an antidote the perfect vaccine
for ever
and ever and ever against the only virus
that can kill you
forever and ever and that is sin
shall we pray yes thank you very much
heavenly father
thank you that this great controversy
will not
continue at infinitum
that you will bring this thing to a
close
and that you will wipe away every tear
and that we may experience what it is
like
to live in a world of harmony
where everybody
knows and obeys god
as an act of love
help us to
decide for that kingdom in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications
to watch the next video
click here
thank you